[Music]
so I'm a massive DC fan since I was
about four years old I've grown up on
the comics and have always preferred
them over Marvel
however Aquaman was always a hero that
was never to interested in and found
completely unreliable
this guy just didn't have the cool
factor for me and I realized that a lot
of people felt the same way when I saw
the character being lampooned on Robot
Chicken then when I picked up the new 52
booth Justice League origin that all
changed here was a guy who could control
great white sharks and get the fish part
of your brain to eat itself and was
generally a badass DC are clearly very
conscious of the characters image and
there is no bigger testament to this
than the 2018 movie Aquaman as someone
who has actually enjoyed the majority of
the DC films even Batman V Superman I
was quite excited for this but I've
tried to keep it out of my mind as the
company often disappointed with their
film adaptations I'm happy to say though
that Aquaman completely blew me away
from beginning to end the movie is a
complete spectacle that features some of
the best action and special effects that
I've seen in a comic-book movie the
screen is awash with color and the way
that the characters anime underwater is
so breathtaking and subtle at the same
time that you forget that you're
watching people being pulled up and down
on a green screen within the first few
seconds of zenit this is a real tour de
force and by the movies midpoint I knew
it was the best DC live-action movie
that I'd seen since the Dark Knight
Rises Jason Momoa is fascinating as a
flawed hero and really feels like he's a
reluctant King that is fulfilling his
duty for the greater good it's a
brilliant choice to make him the Han
Solo of the sea and he finds the perfect
Princess Leia in amber herds Meera
both are really captivating in each
scene that they appear in and feel like
they are on an epic quest to save the
world Patrick Wilson too takes charge as
a villain that is quite easy to relate
as king or narrow definitely aspects of
his personality I sided with and seeing
flashes of trapped ills and dolphins
really rallies you to his cause there
are some aspects that didn't like such
as the absolutely atrocious pit bull
cover of Africa by Cotto basically I
just thought oh I having a joke with our
first cuz Aquaman and Mira walk out of
the sea like like an episode of Baywatch
and this pitbull song is playing and
it's just horrendous
but anyway also Black Manta feels pretty
skipped over it sucks really sure and
he's not really elevated to be the large
threat and nemesis that he should be
these gripes are minor however and there
is a lot to love here for comic book
fans I never imagined I'd see throne of
Atlantis on the big screen like this but
James wand is a spectacular job of
bringing it to life Atlantis as a
location is vibrant fully realized and
completely dwarfed my expectations
Aquaman completely recaptured my love
for DC Comics and got me interested in a
character that I was never invested in
all of these aspects are no mean feat
and showcase just how good the film is
Aquaman is a blast from start to finish
and while it's not perfect it still had
me walking out of the cinema with a
smile on my face it scores an 8.5 out of
10 so what your thoughts on Aquaman did
you enjoy it and what do you hope to see
in the future from DC comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video and don't mind having things
ruined then make sure you check out my
spoiler talk on the film which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]